Now this course isn't about vagrant or
virtual machines.
That was just some overhead
work you needed to accomplish
to get to this point.
You're now logged into a Linux box.
Whenever you get to this prompt,
I want you to ignore all of that
virtual machines and
vagrant stuff as much as possible.
Yes technically this computer is
just a virtual machine sitting on
your computer.
But that's not too different than what
you'll be doing as you start setting up
your own web servers.
Most likely you'll be given
a virtual machine from a service
provider like Amazon.
And you're log in to it via SSH.
This experience is pretty much the same
as what you have configured now
on your computer.
You are remotely connected to
a completely different computer.
What does that mean?
You can do anything
here on this machine.
And it will have no lasting
impact on your personal computer.
Remember, this is an entirely
different computer.
You can turn it off.
Throw it away.
Rebuild it any time you want.
So I want you to have no fear
when SSHed into that computer.
You will not break
anything on your computer.
Now, let's get comfortable with this new
computer, your Linux virtual machine.
And see how it organizes all of
the files you'll be working with.